قال الرئيس بوتين ان هدف الولايات المتحده
ومن سماهم اتباعها في الغرب هو تفكيك
روسيا واشرى في تصريحات تلفزيونيه الى ان
روسيا ستسعى لبناء ما وصفه بنظام عالمي
متعدد الاقطاب قائم على اساس احترام مصالح
جميع الدول
هدفهم واحد وهو تفكيك دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق وعلى راسها روسيا ومن ثم
قد يقبلون في صفوف ما تسمى بالعائله
المتحضره هذا ما تريد فعله الولايات
المتحده انا على يقين من هذا والجميع يدرك
ذلك بمن فيهم اتباع الولايات المتحده لكن
لاسباب مختلفه مرتبطه في المقام الاول
باعتمادهم الكبير على واشنطن في المجالين
الاقتصادي والدفاعي ومع ذلك اتباع واشنطن
يدركون جيدا انه في اطار هذا الصراع فان
كل ما تفعله واشنطن يصب حصرا في مصالحها
الانانيه روسيا لا تستطيع ولن تتصرف بهذه
الطريقه وفي النهايه موقف موسكو هو النضال
من اجل قيام عالم متعدد الاقطاب قائما على
اساس احترام الجميع على الساحه الدوليه